some of you have been homeless
some of you have risked the rejection of
your families to pursue your education
many of you have laying awake at night
wondering how on Earth you were going to
support your parents and your kids and
many of you know what it's like to live
not just month to month or day to day
but meal to meal you'll experience
illnesses and losses crises and setbacks
that will come out of nowhere and knock
you off your feet
but unlike so many other young people
you have already developed the
resilience and the maturity that you
need to pick yourself up and dust
yourself off and keep moving through the
pain keep moving forward you have all
made it here today through the same
combination of unyielding determination
sacrifice and a whole lot of hard work
juggling multiple jobs to support your
families and pay your tuition we are all
created equal all entitled to life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness
we've we've lost the habit of friendship
and sometimes I I was surprised reading
studies at how lonely people are you
know how difficult it is for some people
to prioritize friendship friendship for
me is a tool and I think it's an
important tool for all of us because we
are not meant to do this life alone it
is too hard we know that our greatness
comes when we appreciate each other's
strengths when we learn from each other
when we lean on each other because it's
never been each person for themselves no
we're all in this together we always
have been we we don't let our
differences tear us apart because we
know that our greatness comes when we
appreciate each other's strengths we
question our value our worth we question
how we look how we talk where we're from
um there are people with power who want
us to stay small they want us to stay
doubtful and so our cultures reinforce
that those feelings are real they are
not crazy they are they are
indoctrinated in us all and we carry
them around with us our entire lives and
I don't care how far you go whether you
go to the White House you are constantly
batting away those negative messages of
being not enough and yes I deal with
that too in order to break these cycles
of negativity you got to get up every
day and do the work right before you
that means getting your education when
the opportunity presents itself and then
focusing on that doing the work doing
your homework getting to the next stage
in life because if you take those small
steps over time you build up a lifetime
of another story for yourself no one can
do that for you if we're taught to be
loved if we if we are greeted with
gladness in our own homes that kind of
stuff is what fills a kid up and it's an
important reminder to us as parents you
know particularly as we're grappling in
with what do we need to give our kids
you know sometimes we give them stuff
they don't even need we focus on stuff
were guilty about not having you know
the best putting them in the best
schools and having the best resources we
worry that we don't have what it takes
to make our kids succeed because maybe
we didn't get an education or we never
get had a chance to see what college was
like you don't dwell on what you don't
have we use laughter we move through
things you don't talk about your
problems you just keep going fear is a
monster I realize so much of it is is
motivated by our inability to understand
where our fears are really coming from
because fear is an important emotion it
can keep us safe it is very necessary so
fear is an important emotion it can save
us but it can also keep us stuck if
we're not careful even if you don't
start out with much if you work hard and
do what you're supposed to do you should
be able to build a decent life for
yourself and an even better life for
your kids and grandkids that's how they
raised us
if they could raise beams of Steel to
the sky send a man to the Moon connect
the world with the touch of a button
then then surely we can keep on
sacrificing and building for our own
kids and grandkids and even after my
father was diagnosed with multiple
sclerosis and he struggled to walk
relying on crutches just to get himself
out of bed each morning
my father hardly ever missed a day of
work
see that blue collar job helped to pay
the small portion of my college tuition
that wasn't covered by loans or grants
or my work study or my summer jobs
and my dad was so proud to pay that
tuition bill on time each month
even taking out loans when he fell short
see he never wanted me to miss a
registration deadline because his check
was late
that's my story you all have faced
challenges far greater than anything I
or my family have ever experienced there
is a limited box that we are put in yeah
and if we live by that limited
definition we we miss out on a lot of
who we are but it takes taking the time
to know who you are to be able to deal
with
the onslaught of negative messages that
you're bound to get so for me I came
into this with a pretty clear sense of
myself and some of that comes with age
some of that comes with experience some
some of that comes from being fortunate
enough to been raised by a loving mother
strong focused and a father who loved me
dearly so I fortunately came into this
situation with a really clear sense of
who I was
so when you hear
the smack talking from outside the world
it's easy to sort of brush that off
because I know who I am
I used to tell some of the young people
I worked with way back in Chicago days
that I used to hate the the question
what do you want to be when you grow up
because it assumes that at some point
you stop becoming and you just are
something and that would be a sad thing
you know to think that this is it
um and that's one of the things I've
learned that there is there's so many
phases to life this even as big as being
first lady and living in the white house
has been this is still just a portion of
a very bigger Journey that I have yet to
know the outcome and I won't know it
until I'm laying laying down it's just
ever evolving these are just phases you
know and this has been a very
interesting phase and a very impactful
phase but there's more to come and if
you're going out into the world as a
professional and you don't know who you
are you don't know what you want you
don't know how much you're worth then
you have to be brave you have to count
on the kindness and goodness of others
to bestow that goodness on you when you
should be
working to get it you're on your own
because you deserve it because you know
your own value you gotta just sort of
surround yourself with people who uplift
you who hold you up there is somebody
out there who loves you and who is
waiting to love you and you just have to
find them and that means you have to
make room for them and if you're
surrounded by a bunch of low-life folks
who aren't supporting you then there is
no room for the people who do love you
so I want you all to go out there be
great build great lives for yourself
pursue your own version of happiness and
please please always always do your part
to help others do the same